- I would say a bond between
the inmate and the horse
is one of the most important
things that they learn.
When they actually start
to bond with that horse,
they will become better
trainers, they will become
better people.
I think that's good that
they feel that much pride
in their horses.
It's good to have pride in
something, especially in prison.
(contemplative music)
(birds chattering)
Go right up behind his ears
a little bit with that rope.
Now when that gets up there, he may jump, so.
Done pretty good.
My name's Hank Curry.
I'm the head horse trainer
here at the Northern Nevada
Correctional Center.
I've been here 15 years now,
and I'm in charge of about
20 to 25 inmates.
We're taking a completely
wild horse and trying
to domesticate them, get
them where they're a gentle,
usable horse.
The inmates put in applications
to come to work out here.
According to their behavior in
prison, we review all of that
and try to decide whether
or not they could possibly
become horse trainers.
To start out with, we
take a totally wild horse,
and I have my guys actually
put them in a round corral.
We don't allow them to
rope them or anything else.
They have to actually make
contact with their hands.
Most of the inmates have
maybe ridden a horse
once or twice in their
life, so it takes a lot
of guts, and it takes
a lot of determination.
- This guy right here didn't
want nothin' to do with me
and now he's my little
buddy and he follows me
everywhere I go.
- It's just a moment
where you bond, you know,
and you become like best friends.
This guy only did it
within the last few weeks.
It's pretty amazing.
I mean, I'm not doing time
until I go back to camp.
You know, and that's when the clock
starts for me as far as
realizing where I'm at.
When I'm out here I'm free.
- [Hank] In the last few
years, we've developed
a lot of horses that have
been used by the Fish and Game
wardens, the Forestry Service.
The Sheriff's Department
actually has a mounted group
and those were horses
trained by this program.
I think that, you know, this job is
kind of inspirational.
It's not like regular prison
where everybody's running
around being foul-mouthed,
you know, being a tough guy
and everything else.
Doesn't work out here.
Horses don't care who you
are, how big or how tough
you are; they will
equalize the playing field
if you want to play tough.
I see a great deal of
change in all these guys.
They seem to mature.
They're functioning;
they know how to work;
they know how to hold a job.
So often it's changed their lives.